[Music]
i guess tower was a more than
appropriate name
look at that place
the signals coming from within that main
structure
somewhere up top
we're gonna need to find a way in
oh
oh
uh
blue
so the demon is here
did you think i would let you walk right
into my tower
my
power
i think not
my facility is locked down
there is nothing you can do here
he seems confident
yes he does but fortunately it's
misplaced when the lockdown triggered
there was a power spike in what i
presume was a security building
i've marked it on the map
the only way in is to remove the
lockdown
moves
we're not getting in the tower while the
lockdown is still active
just like the others
he is closed
back
this is where the lockdown was triggered
i'm so standing
i'm looking forward
the lockdown protocol should be simple
to reverse let me see three two one done
oh
what is it
this
this place is an interrogation facility
run by our elite friend back there chad
lock
his reputation is
not good
neither is mine
you're going to need to manually
activate the gravity lift
i've marked it on your map
[Applause]
this location acts as a holding facility
prisoners are captured funneled through
to check lock and then onto somewhere
they call the house of reckoning which
is
suitably ominous and banished sounding
um
is
you're not
safe sports
let's go the gravity lifts powered up
chief more spartan armor and the source
of the distress signal
we're too late
a deployable threat sensor it appears to
lock onto and highlight any targets in
range
could be useful
this armor belonged to a spartan named
hudson griffin
sensor logs suggest he was alive when
the armor was removed
forcibly
it's a long shot but he might still be
alive
ugh
[Applause]
[Music]
you have overreached demon
this is not a place to come by choice
[Music]
you have overreached
this is not a place
he's
about what you would expect
for an elite
who specializes in torture
you have overreached demon
this is not a place
about what you would expect
for an elite
who specializes in torture
[Music]
we gotta fight keep hiding humans
[Music]
so easy
[Music]
message
weakness
oh
i'll tear you apart
[Music]
so
oh no spartan griffin he's still alive
we need to get him out of there
where's check lock
unknown
[Music]
welcome to my tower master chief
it is where you will be broken
it is where you will give up your
secrets
the wall's retracted watch your back he
could come from anywhere
griffin's threat sensor can help you
locate chat
weekly
see you soon
much better
the walls retracted watch your back he
could come from anywhere
let us test you demons
so
oh
we need to get him out of that machine
shut this thing down
working on it
okay
be ready i'm going to cut him loose
it's you
you're alive
the banished
i tried to stop them
i tried
to easy
you're safe now
the banished they
they have something they call the
conservatory
that's all i know
it's picked up north of here
dig site
i couldn't stop them
but you can
you have to
consider it done
good
good
the others the sperms
did you
i'll find them
echo 216 all channels can you hear me i
repeat can you hear me
chief big guy your motion tracker isn't
moving
ah come on come on give me anything
chief i
respond please
did you find the source of the signal
whatever is down there either has to
come with us or be left behind
can you hear me
a dig site on the ring
this conservatory must be some sort of
forerunner installation
what do you suppose they're after it's
time to go
me
you